Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di Cucina Buttata. Dopo il
successo enorme che la ricetta del CrispyMcBacon ha
avuto, abbiamo deciso di prendere un
pochino di consigli da parte vostra e di
seguire un'altra ricetta che va alla
grande nei fast food. Sto parlando del Chicken McNuggets. Si chiamano Chicken McNuggets?
I polletti. Prima di partire col
procedimento vorrei inoltre ringraziare
nostro cugino che ci dà la possibilità
di cucinare all'interno del suo cucino
per arredare sempre in maniera
impeccabile questo posto e adesso
abbiamo anche una meravigliosa carta
da parati con delle scimmie che hanno
dei nomi che non ricordo. Finiti questi
ringraziamenti direi di partire subito con
gli ingredienti per fare i Chicken
McNuggets. Per prima cosa serve del pollo
offerta speciale, della cipolla tritata,
sale. E questo fondamentalmente è quello
che serve per fare il poletto in se. Poi
per l'impanatura invece avremo bisogno
di un sacco di altre cose che sono: latte,
un uovo, amido di mais, acqua
frizzantissima, farina, olio per friggere.
Non so chi ha aperto questa roba al
contrario, mi sento come le patatine
fritte, chi apre le patatine fritte io
lo ammazzerei al contrario. La prima cosa che
faremo è preparare il pollo interno
quindi questa roba qui possiamo
toglierla adesso. Bene ora che non ci
abbiamo più in mezzo ai piedi possiamo
lavorare "Oh"...Abbiamo preso ispirazione per
fare questa ricetta dal Mc e da
soprattutto un canale che ringraziamo e
e che citiamo qua sotto che si chiama
Munchies, dove ripropongono effettivamente
la ricetta dei nuggets di pollo e tra
tutte quante ci sembrava quella un
pochino più fighetta. Prendiamo 450
grammi di pollo. Non ho il grembiule!
Cacchio! (Chef Rico)
Vai...Partiamo subito ad affettare il pollo
Ma quanto li devi far grandi? (Rico)- Piccolini...grandi
Tagliamo un pochino a cacchio. Tagliare
ti fa proprio sentire uno Chef, sei d'accordio?
Considera te lo volevo dire, sembri pratico (Rico)
Mi scompare il dito sotto il pollo e non so dove sia. Si
è vero è tutto lo stesso colore, il mio dito
il pollo.-Fatelo con i guanti (Rico)- Gialli, per pulire piatti.
A questo punto io userò questo
robettino della Kenwood per metterci
dietro, dietro, dietro
Ma che c'hai oggi? (Rico)-Non so parlare oggi
E' che quando ho le mani sporche non riesco
a pensare. Fammele lavare infatti
Una cosa che io sto scoprendo cucinando,
quando prendi ispirazione da delle
ricette americane, la cosa più comoda, piuttosto che pesare ogni singola cosa
è quella di comprarsi questi robetti qua, i misurini per i cucchiaini, i misurini
per le tazze. Vi lascio il link qua
sotto perché sono molto più comodi e
semmai vorrete rifare questa ricetta o
ricette americane in generale, io vi
consiglio di averli perché sono
veramente veloci e sporchi di meno
Suggeriscono di aggiungere un cucchiaino
da tè di come lo chiami becchime?
La cipolla. Cipolla granulare. Siccome io ho
messo lì metà ne metterò mezzo
cucchiaino-Ma perché non lo fai tutto? Tanto se li sturamo (Rico)
Se mettessi tutto insieme
secondo me esploderebbe questo coso
Invece così gli do più aria per poter
girare. Ho detto una cazzata?- Ma scusa ma non ha un
coperchio quel coso? (Rico) - Non c'ha un coperchio
la tua bocca?
Ce l'ha - Allora puoi comprimerlo tutto, che te frega! (Rico)
Loro aggiungono il sale all'aglio che noi
non abbiamo trovato grazie a Dio
e quindi aggiungeremo semplicemente un cucchiaino da the di sale normale e direi che
può bastare, perché poi loro ne aggiungono altro ancora, però secondo me poi diventa troppo salato. Mmm no
Fai sempre di testa tua, segui la ricetta e vedi che succede (Rico)
Tu segui la via del silenzio e guarda sarai
meravigliato dalle risposte che avrai
Chiudiamo. Ho un po' di paura, ho un po' di timore...Cacchio!
Ok...questo
Qualora non lo sappiate
sia i Chicken McNuggets che tipo le
Pringles hanno una pasta di pollo e una
pasta di patate che poi viene fatta a
forma di patate. Per questo che hanno
una consistenza diversa e buonissima
Dovremmo farle le Pringles su una volta...C'avevi ragione comunque, guarda
perfetto! Mamma mia! Togliamo questo, tra parentesi
Kenwood se ci vuoi sponsorizzare. Sono
stanco di farvi pubblicità a gratis. Allora il
composto viene pazzesco, l'unica palla è che
non si può assaggiare il composto crudo per vedere se è buono di sale perché
sennò ti piglia la morte. Ragazzi mi raccomando quando
toccate il pollo lavatevi le mani
igienizzate benissimo le superfici.
Teoricamente non si dovrebbe se non
sbaglio nemmeno utilizzare il legno
perché è assorbente. Non so perché ma da
quando mi hanno scritto su Instagram
questa cosa qui io ho il terrore
Prendiamo delle teglie, le foderiamo con della carta
Che p***e foderà le cose
Ecco, dovrei tagliarle? - No (Rico) - Si se mi hai
detto no tu dovevo taglarle
Mamma mia che bello trovare modi per
non fare niente, cioè viene una m***a ma...
Ma perché lo usi al contrario? (Rico) - Perché taglia meglio la punta, non so perché. Prendete una bacinellina
d'acqua, vi togliete gli anelli, vi
bagnate le dita. Dovete formare tipo dei
Chicken McNuggets nudi, quanto un Chicken McNuggets. Come sarebbe bello avere un
fratello che mi desse una mano adesso a
fare questa cosa più velocemente, se solo
non fosse così impegnato a fare una
ripresa che comunque risulterà noiosa...Senti
sto per fare delle delle tegole - Ne fai uno a forma di pene? (Chef Rico)
No Enrico - Perché? - Perché no è volgare, ne faccio una a forma di cuore
Va bene, allora ti do' una mano a farli (Rico)
L'unica palla è doverli congelare perché
tutto quello che non riesco a preparare
non riesco a congelarlo e non congelandolo non lo creo, non lo creo, non lo mangia il Purci e Roby, capito?
Mi hai mandato in pappa il cervello, non sono molto appetitosi. Quelli del Mc so fatti meglio Guglielmo (Rico)
Aspè, dammi...cioè ma tu non cioè mmm - Ti ho ammutolito ahahaha (Rico)
Comunque si mi hai ammutolito "Bag ua a"
Una volta finito il procedimento dovrete
avere più o meno diciamo una trentina
abbondante di nuggets che metteremo in
freezer per due ore. Due ore dopo i
nugget si saranno ghiacciati e allo
stesso tempo gli ospiti di questa casa
si saranno duplicati, tra parentesi
abbiamo anche la padrona di questa casa
che c'ha anche ripetuto i nomi di tutta
questa gente qui. Com'è che sono? Lui è il
signor Cesare, William, Josh, Johnson, il piccolo Franklin, Bach
Rupert...Meredit la smemorata e Margaret la smemorata. Gli unici che ho
soprannominato io no...e poi il Camaleangolo
Iniziamo a preparare i nostri nugget, la
prima cosa importante da fare è prendere
un termometro da cucina...no Giulia non è il tuo ti dà fastidio?
No è l'invidia che parla sai? - Io ho due sonde (Giulia) -  Due sonde? Si ti dico io dove metterle
La cosa che faremo sarà utilizzare tre ciotole, in questa
metteremo diciamo i nostri
ingredienti secchi, in questo quelli
liquidi e poi utilizzeremo perché qui su
Manchies lo usano un impasto per la
tempura. Perché? Perché a tutti piace la tempura
Fondamentalmente è più soffice, ne puoi
mangiare molti di più, non lo so perché
sinceramente, li seguirò, speriamo che
vengano bene. Per la parte secca avremo
bisogno di mezza tazza, poi naturalmente
i grammi ve li metto qua sotto nell'infobox, se volete utilizzarli...mezza tazza
di farina e 4 cucchiai di amido di mais.
Per gli ingredienti invece liquidi
abbiamo un quarto di tazza di latte...un
uovo. Com'è che si chiama la impanatura? - Cipolla
E infine l'impanatura per la tempura, una tazza di
farina
che mi sembra un botto, boh vabbè...una tazza di
farina - Devi panarle quindi ti servirà (Chef Mario)
E forse si che ti devo dire - Più che altro sono 30 nuggets (Rico)
Col sorriso comunque, cioè nessuno ha...cioè sta  serietà manco non lo so. Un cucchiaio di amido di mais
Tre quarti di acqua molto frizzante
fredda. Questo è frizzantissima è perfetta
Madonna se è...acido! (Rico)
Mettete i guanti perché se vi tocca la pelle.
Stiamo utilizzando un termometro per
monitorare, il problema è che è un po' rumoroso, aspettate, ecco. 336 no! Non ho monitorato un c***o
Faremo due giri di fratture, la prima a 160 gradi
per un minuto e poi un'altra a
temperatura più alta. Ti prego stai zitto ti prego! Ma perché
ho preso priva lui di tutti quanti? Chissà
perché. Oh il secondo è il cuore. Un giro
qui, un giro qui, torniamo qui e poi qua
I segreti dei fast food (Mario) - Ma tu
sei il moralizzatore dell'angolo delle
Delle palle stanno venendo tranquilla - Regà mi avete fatto venire una voglia di McDonald (Roby)
Tranquilla ce l'hai qui
No ragazzi stanno venendo delle palle enormi - Figuriamoci questo (Roby)
La prima frittura è questo, devono essere
pallidini quando escono
Gu te prego sto termometro però cioè...
Pensa che io sono dentro questo incubo più di te,
perché sto pure imparando. Oddio pure tu stai
messo male perché stai dovendo
riprendere questo incubo
Passo nella farina, poi passo nell'uovo e non mi si attacca l'uovo sopra. Ti prego, ti prego!
Ho capito che è un'emergenza. Ora questi si stanno
gonfiando di meno però temo di aver
fatto troppo bene la tempura - Troppo bene adesso è un parolone (Rico) - Abbiamo finito la cottura a 160
gradi che vi porterà ad avere dei
nugget  così, ci sono resi conto che
effettivamente nonostante...dei nuggets (Rico)
Nuggets è il plurale in inglese, noi stiamo parlando italiano
quindi quando tu prendi in prestito una
parola inglese dall'italiano tu dovresti
sempre usarla solo al singolare,
quindi à nugget. Non sono quanti
followers hai ma quanti follower hai. Ora finito questo momento possiamo parlare, comunque pochi tu
Avremo un nugget così - Nuggets (Rico) - Un nuggets così
E' abbastanza grosso, quindi dovete farli
ancora più piccoli, ah ho capito "Fanno
schifo". Ero pronto a prenderli e lanciarteli
in faccia. Finita questa cottura a
160 gradi dovremo passare alla seconda
cottura, 375 fahrenheit che adesso
scoprirò quanto sono in celsius
Ragazzi se avete bisogno di un termometro
da cucina video ve li ho messi un pochino in
descrizione se li volete prendere.
Non prendete questo! Ma non c'è fra
quelli. A 190 gradi dovete friggere
adesso. Una cosa positiva di questa roba
qui è che potete prendere e buttarli
insieme perché non c'è più il rischio
che si incolliino l'uno con l'altro...Questo
qui è il risultato finale
No forse è meglio non parlarne. Ketchup altrimenti rimangono tipo il
diamante dell'oceano di Rose. Ho un regalo per te. Che cosa è? E' il brillocco di carta stagnola dell'oceano"
Cameleangolo
Occhio che mo ti caca tutto. Ecco lo sapevo
Ok, non troppo di più. Ragazzi è difficilissimo
Regà non se ci ass...Non so se ci assomigliano
ma so boni. Che schifo? Quello che hai fatto. Ah vabbè
Scusate...un secondo solo...li preferisco senza ketchup. Manca un po' di sale. No bisognava
salarli alla fine. Aspetta un attimo
Comunque ragazzi siamo arrivati alla
fine di questo video, è notte fuori, ci
abbiamo messo i secoli per fare questa
ricetta. Che dire, noi ci vediamo sempre
la prossima settimana di domenica alle 12
Ciao